Hello everybody, and welcome to our mini symposium on
advances in cancer epigenetics. Very excited
to see and have all of you. So my name is Daria
Gaikalova. I am from University of Maryland, and today I'm
going to co-chair this session with my colleague, Dr.
Eneda Toska from Johns Hopkins University.
And just to give you a brief introduction about epigenetics,
epigenetics means above genetics.
So all the information that is coded in our genome, but not in the
sequence itself, will be considered epigenetics.
And we're going
to talk about different aspects of epigenetics, about nucleosome
positioning, about CpG
DNA methylation, about chromatin and histone marks
modifications,
how they play a role in regulational transcription.
We'll especially cover some of the histone modifications that I want to
introduce. Repressive mark H3K27
tri-methylation, H3K36 active
body marker, H3K4 tri-methylation
active promoter, and an active enhancer mark.
And today, we're going to cover different cancer
sites. We're going to have speakers talking about esophageal cancer, lung
cancer, colon, and prostate cancer.
We're going to talk about development of cancer from normal to
tumor.
We'll talk about how aging has similar aspects
together along with cancer,
and we'll learn how
overall DNA methylation is decreased in a cancer
during formation, but we see a local hypermethylation
of CpG islands and as well as how we see
increased accumulation of histone modifications
abnormality as well as mutation in
epigenetic regulators.
And what's interesting is we will also touch a little
bit about epigenetic regulators who help to write
all this modification, such as DNA methylation,
EZH2,
methyltransferases who help to add methyl groups to histone
marks, and for example, represent a heavily
repressive mark H3K27 tri-methylation
or create active histone mark. We're going to
talk about erasers, who actually remove the modification both
from DNA and histones. We're going to cover a couple of
demethylases, ones that remove methyl groups from
H3K4 and create active marks
of promoters and enhancers, and
H3K36, once again, active body genes.
And we're going to talk about readers as well, ones that
recognize all these modifications like
CHD7, that recognize H3K4
tri-methylation and provide nucleosome
repositioning using ATP energy. And what's
important about all these epigenetic regulators is
that they've been very actively studied from the
aspect of development of epigenetic drugs.
So that's also what will be covered in our session today.
And with no further ado, I would like to invite here
Ace Xie from University of British Columbia, who is going
to talk to us about CHD7 in prostate cancer.
Thank you.
All right.
So, good afternoon. My name is Ace. I'm from Dr.
Weizhu Wan's lab based in Vancouver, Canada.
It is a great-- Sorry.
So it is a great honor for me to be here and share one of our recent
studies, which is...
Can you guys hear it?
Keep some distance.
Uh-huh.
You don't need to talk that close.
Should be okay right now. Yeah. Sorry.
Distance.
Oh, sorry.
All right. So it is a great honor to be here and share one of our recent studies,
which is on Chromatin remodeler CHD7 drives lineage plasticity
and modulates replication competence in neuroendocrine prostate cancer.
So neuroendocrine prostate cancer, or NEPC, is an aggressive subtype of advanced
prostate cancer that often emerges following androgen receptor pathway inhibition.
Its incidence has been increasing over the years and now accounts for up to 20% of
the late-stage disease.
In contrast to the initial prostatic adenocarcinoma, which depends
on the AR signaling, NEPC cells often undergo lineage
plasticity by losing dependence on the AR signaling and
relapse with an acquisition of a neuroendocrine phenotype, and therefore
resistance to the conventional pathway inhibition.
Current treatment options for NEPC are still limited to platinum-based
chemotherapy, such as cisplatin.
However, the responses are very short-lived.
There has been no effective targeted therapies designed for this disease, and
therefore, there is still an urgent need to understand the molecular mechanism
driving the NEPC development and aggressiveness.
So to study NEPC, our labs established a unique platform,
321-321 RPDX model.
So after the castration in the host 321, the model fully
recapitulates the entire transition from adenoma to NEPC, which
is also observed in the original patient.
So using this model, we are able to collect samples from different time
points and conduct longitudinal analyses to examine the cellular and
molecular modifications across different stages of the transition.
So extensive research by our lab and other study groups has pointed out a
significant role of epigenetic regulation in driving this transdifferentiation
process.In particular, unlike adenocarcinoma, NEPC
cells exhibit a salt-and-pepper chromatin pattern,
which suggests that chromatin modification occurred during this process.
And a key component influencing this chromatin landscape modification
is the activity of chromatin remodelers, which modify the structure and
positioning of the nucleosomes, and thereby modulating the chromatin landscape
and the downstream pathways.
However, the key remodelers driving the NEPC still remain largely unknown.
And therefore, in this study, we aim to identify the key remodelers for driving
NEPC development and aggressiveness.
We hypothesize that chromatin remodelers activate early and sustain during the
entire NEPC progression, function as an upstream regulator that drives not
only NE lineage transition, but also the maintenance of aggressive phenotypes in
the terminal EPC. Importantly, targeting these remodelers and/or
their downstream factors may provide better therapeutic opportunities.
So to identify the candidate chromatin remodeler, we perform
longitudinal transcriptomic analysis on samples collected from
three different time points. So pre-castration,
post-castration 12 weeks, which is the early stage of NEPC development, and
relapse 331H. So we first look into the 82 genes
and identify the upregulated remodelers in the
terminal EPC by comparing 331H to 31.
And then we further compare the upregulated genes in the post-castration 12 weeks
to 331H to identify the ones that could be induced early.
And CHD7 emerged as the study candidate by showing progressive
activation and high sustained expression in the terminal EPC.
So to validate our finding, we examine CHD7 expression along with
adenome and NE lineage markers on the protein level across three phases.
And what we observe is that consistent with RNA-seq data, CHD7
expression is minimal in the pre-castration and induced early at the
post-castration 12 weeks. However, at this stage, AR signaling has been shut down,
but NE lineage has yet to show up.
Importantly, CHD7 expression continues to increase and highly
sustains in the terminal EPC where NE lineage has
established.
All these results together indicate that CHD7 is an early event of the
NEPC development.
So to assess its clinical relevance, we look into the clinical
samples and consistent with our data, that
CHD7 upper regulations is consistently observed in EPC tumors,
indicating that CHD7 is not only an early event, but also highly
sustained and clinical relevant to the terminal NEPC.
So as CHD7 is an early event, we next investigated whether
CHD7 could promote this transdifferentiation process.
So to do so, we first overexpressed the gene in the adenoma cell line and
treated the cells with AR targeted therapy.
And what we observe is that overexpression of the genes lead to increased
expression of NE markers and transcription factors, suggesting that CHD7
upregulation leads to the transdifferentiation.
On the other side, the knockdown of the gene leads to reduced NE marker and
transcription factor expression, indicating that CHD7
contributes to the maintenance of the NE phenotype in the terminal EPC as well.
So to further define how CHD7 shapes the
chromatin landscape as a chromatin remodeler, we perform
ATAC-seq in the control and the knockdown cells.
And what we observe is that knockdown of the gene preferentially
contributed to a global shift toward a closing state.
And then to further understand whether these modifications are directly mediated by
CHD7,
we integrated the data with CHD7 ChIP-seq in the
control cells, and we observed 94% of the CHD7
bound regions with modified accessibility are predominantly
lost accessibility, which indicates that CHD7 directly
maintains the chromatin state at its binding sites.
Importantly, these regions corresponded to 1805 genes, which
CHD7 can directly regulate.
So to understand the functional consequences
of CHD7-mediated chromatin accessibility, we integrated the
data of 1805 genes with downregulated genes observed
in the RNA-seq, and we identified 563
genes as a direct set of CHD7 direct transcriptional targets.
Furthermore, the pathway enrichment analysis indicate strong
enrichment in the neural fate commitment, DNA replication, and the cell
cycle progression. As we look into the pathways, the
heat map shows key representative targets, including a lineage transcription factor
such as ASCL1, SOX1, and
also replication stress machinery, including RPA and RFC
components. All these results indicate that CHD7 directly
orchestrates transcription programs governing lineage identity and
also replication competence.
Then we proceeded to validate those insights
functionally, and we observed that knockdown of the gene significantly reduced the
cell growth and DNA synthesis. Additionally,
DNA damage has been accumulating, and also
apoptosis has been increased as well.
Indeed, while knockdown of the gene impaired DNA replication, the concurrent
accumulation of the DNA damage indicate that there's unresolved
replication-associated stress.
And efficient resolution of
such stress requires activation of ATR checkpoint,
which also relies on the replication stress sensory machinery, including
RPA and RFC components. However, these components has been disrupted
by CHD7 transcriptionally, and therefore, in this part, we hypothesize
that CHD7 is required for efficient ATR
checkpoint activation during this NEPC progression.
Indeed, once we knock down the gene, what we observe is that although the
protein level of ATR and checkpoint remains unchanged, however,
phosphorylated form of these two genes are significantly reducedThis
indicates that the knockdown of the gene really impairs the ATR checkpoint activity
in the NEPC cells.
So based on these mechanistic insights, we look into whether
this axis has any kind of implications in the
therapeutic response, in particular to the cisplatin.
As cisplatin induces DNA crosslinks and therefore will lead into
replication stress,
we wanted to see whether cisplatin would enhance CHD7
expression and also boost the ATR checkpoint activity, and
whether targeting this axis can sensitize the NEPC cells to the
cisplatin.
So upon the cisplatin treatment, we observed a progress
increase in the CHD7 expression and also the ATR checkpoint
activity. And then to see whether this axis contributes to this drug
response functionally, we treated the cells
in control and knockdown cells and observed that IC50 of the cisplatin
is greatly reduced. This indicates that the knockdown
increased the sensitivity to the cisplatin.
However, there has been no approved drugs for
CHD7, and therefore, we proposed to see whether the downstream
effector checkpoint inhibition could enhance the cisplatin response in
the NEPC cells.
So we first validated the effective checkpoint inhibition in the
cells using the inhibitor, and then we proceed to combine
cisplatin with the checkpoint inhibition.
And what we observed is that the combination leads to increased DNA
accumulation and also apoptosis.
Consistent with that, the cell viability is greatly reduced with the combination
compared to either treatment alone.
So overall, we identify CHD7 as an early
regulator and is really highly relevant to the clinical NEPC.
We examined that it promotes NE differentiation process
and also regulates NE phenotype proliferation and survival in the terminal
NEPC.
Mechanistically, we look into that CHD7 directly regulates
chromatin accessibility and sustain the transcriptional programs
underlying the lineage identity and replication competence.
And also the gene enables efficient ATR checkpoint
activation under replication stress, and therefore this axis mediates
the cisplatin tolerance.
And for that, I want to thank everybody for attending, thank my supervisor, my
lab members, and open to any questions.
Questions?
Okay. I will start. Great talk. I wanted to ask, what controls
mechanistically the expression of CHD7?
So right now, we haven't
defined the specific upstream regulator for CHD7,
but we do have plenty results to suggest that they're not
directly regulated by AR, because we do have
PDX models which relapse to CRPC instead of NEPC.
And once we look into those models, CHD7 upregulation was not
observed during the early phase. So that suggests that CHD7
should be very NEPC specific instead of a long-term response to the
androgen response.
And also we knocked down AR, and also with enzalutamide in vitro all
suggests that AR does not regulate CHD7.
So in the future, I think with the advantage of our model, we'll proceed
with
multi-omic study to see what directly binds to
CHD7 promoters and
directly regulates the expression.
Great. Over there.
Thank you. I enjoyed your talk. My question is, did you
identify any recurring motifs at the
CHD7 binding sites that were
correlated to its regulated transcriptome?
Yeah.
Did you identify any of those that could potentially be binding or
interacting with CHD7 to help drive this
neuroendocrine lineage?
Yes. We did perform TF motif analysis.
Could you speak into the microphone so we could hear?
Just speak into the microphone.
Yeah. Like that.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. So
we did perform the TF motif analysis, and then
FOXA2, ASCL1, SOX2,
and then several replication-related genes were also observed
in the analysis. So I think in cooperation with all those
factors on CHD7, like you said, promotes NEPC
progression.
Over there.
Thank you for the talk. Could you clarify how CHD7 actually
opens the chromatin? Does it recruit remodeling complexes?
How does it do it?
Yes. We haven't specifically looked at whether if it recruits
other subunits, because right now, unlike
SMARCA4 or two, that it forms BAF complexes.
There hasn't been no specific study talk about how CHD7
specifically work with other subunits to form a large
complex. But with the ATAC-seq, we do
analyze whether CHD7 regulates accessibility
by eviction or the sliding of the nucleosomes, and we
observed that a large amount of this are sliding,
and around 30% is eviction of the
nucleosomes.
Thank you.
So let us all thank Ace for a great talk. Thank you so much.
So our next speaker is Guoliang Li, from
Meharry Medical College, and he's going to talk about
KDM5B on prostate cancer.
Thank you.
Yes.
Good afternoon, and thank you for the opportunity.
My name is Guoliang Li from Meharry Medical College.Today,
I will discuss the essential role of KDM5B SOX9
signaling in the development of therapy-induced
neuroendocrine prostate cancer, also called tNEPC.
So prostate cancer is the second leading cause of cancer-related deaths
in American men. Androgen deprivation therapy,
ADT, is the standard treatment for advanced disease.
Although patients initially respond to ADT,
most tumors eventually recur as castration-resistant
prostate cancer.
Importantly, a subset of these tumors undergo clonal
plasticity and transition into neuroendocrine prostate
cancer, or called NEPC.
This highly aggressive subtype is characterized by
loss of androgen receptor signaling and increased NE
markers, such as neurospecific enolase,
NSE, or synaptophysin, SYN. So remember, these three
is very typical NE markers.
So
currently, there's no targeted therapy for NEPC, and we don't fully
understood the molecular mechanisms driving the transition
to NEPC.
KDM5B is a histone demethylase to
remove methyl group from histone H3.
KDM5B has already been implicated in the
progression of prostate cancer. Our group also
report KDM5B inactivation suppress
prostate tumorigenesis in potent null mouse, and a
knockout of KDM5B reduce cell proliferation in
prostate cancer cells.
Recently, we finished RNA sequence analysis and found
SOX9, a transcription factor, is among the
top genes significantly downregulated by
KDM5B loss in prostate cancer cells.
To further explore genomic alternations of
KDM5B and SOX9 in prostate cancer, we
analyzed the published clinic data sets and
human prostate cancer cells. So one study in the "Nature
Medicine" reported that KDM5B and SOX9
are frequently implicated in about
46.5% and
32.6% NEPC cases respectively.
Importantly,
both protein are highly
expressed in NEPC or NEPC-like cell lines,
such as NCI-H660 or PC3.
Their expression correlates with increased NE marker,
NSE, indicating a strong association
with NE differentiations.
So based on this observation, we hypothesize
KDM5B upregulation could promote
NE transformation through activating SOX9 signalings.
To determine whether KDM5B functional regulate these
processes, we performed loss and
gain-of-function studies.
So as shown in the panels A and B,
knockout of KDM5B significantly
reduce the expression levels of SOX9
and NE marker, including NSE and
SYN.
Conversely, restore KDM5B in
KDM5B knockout cells
rescue the expression of these NE markers and SOX9
in a dose-dependent manners. So this
result demonstrate KDM5B could be the key
regulator for the SOX9 signaling and NE
differentiations in prostate cancer cell lines.
Next, we examine this pathway in
vivo use genetically engineered mouse
model. In PTEN P53
double knock mouse,
surgery castration initially
induce tumor regression. You see the tumor size is reduced,
followed by the recurrency with
NE features. As shown in the West blotting
result, this recurrency tumor exhibit
much higher KDM5B, SOX9, NSE,
and SYN levels compare with naive
or regression tumors. And also,
the IHC confirm the increased
SOX9 and synaptophysin staining in
this recurrent tumor, along with the loss of
androgen receptor signaling. So this in vivo
observations suggest the activation of
KDM5B SOX9 access
is associated with the NE differentiation in
vivo.
To test
the role of KDM5B in the development of
NEPC directly link have
KDM5B overexpression,
KDM5B knockout, and the control cells were
cultured in charcoal-stripped FBS
medium to remove the androgen signaling and
induce
NE differentiations. After three months, you can
see the KDM5B overexpression and the control cell
display a neural-like morphology.
But the KDM5B knockout cell did not.
And the West blotting analysis show NSE, SYN,
the two NE markers... are increased in the control
and the KDM5B overexpression cells, but were
barely detectable in the KDM5B knockout cells.
In parallel, we generated PTEN,
p53, and KDM5B triple knockout mice.
So those triple knockout mice failed
to develop recurrent tumor after castration.
And
the NE marker, like NIC or ISN, were
largely absent in this
triple knockout mouse compared with the double
knockouts. The KDM5B is present in the double knockout mouse.
So this data indicate KDM5B
is really initial for the therapy-induced
NE differentiation and recurrent tumor in the
PTEN p53 mouse model.
So we then investigate the molecular mechanism
undergoing these processes. So
firstly, we want to check if KDM5B affects SOX9
protein stability. So we do the
immunofluorescence to show that SOX9
and KDM5B co-localize in the nucleus
of the prostate cancer cells. And the nuclear SOX9
level, you compare here and here, is remarkably reduced
upon KDM5B knockout. This confirms that
KDM5B can regulate SOX9 expression.
But when we check the
protein stability, and we don't find any
significant change, indicating the regulation
primarily occurs at the transcriptional levels.
So using CHIP-qPCR and the promoter reporter assay,
we demonstrate KDM5B directly binds
SOX9's promoter. Consistently, loss of
KDM5B, knockout KDM5B, reduced the
SOX9 promoter activity as measured by
luciferase activity.
So to further define the
pathway
hierarchy, we knockout SOX9 independently.
So this too is a SOX9 downstream gene or SOX9
associated gene, so just make sure SOX9 is knocked out.
And knockout of SOX9 reduced the expression
levels of NE marker, but had no effect
on the expression of KDM5B.
Same thing in the protein levels. It reduced the protein levels of NE
marker, but no change the protein of the
KDM5B. Conversely, restored
SOX9 in SOX9 knockout cells,
rescued the NE markers, NIC and IS7,
without affecting KDM5B levels. So this
result confirms SOX9 as a
downstream effector, and the KDM5B is a
upstream epigenetic regulator. So based on these
results, we propose a model in
which KDM5B upregulation
activates SOX9 signaling, and this signaling, in turn,
drives the
NE differentiation and the progression to therapy-induced
NEPC.
So currently, our research demonstrates three key points.
The first one is KDM5B is a key regulator for the
neural marker expression in human prostate cancer cells,
and the KDM5B is essential for the NE
development. And the SOX9 signaling
drives NEPC differentiations. So we thank all the
collaborators, and
this research is funded by the NIH and American Cancer
Society. I'm happy to take any questions.
Thank you so much. Great talk. So this now open to
discussion. If you have a question, please say your name and
your institution because this is recorded, so people streaming really wants to
know where the question is coming from. Thank you.
For sure. Yixiang Li from Dana-Farber. A very nice talk.
I noticed in your last slide with the schematics, and you show there's
AKT up. Can you elaborate on the AKT role in this
process? Thank you.
Yeah. Actually,
in our paper in 2020, we first found KDM5B
actually affect AKT signaling. That's why we put AKT
here.
Oh, may I ask? Yeah.
Interesting talk. Well, I'm Xing Yao from UBC Canada.
Well, several curious points. Firstly,
you said NS year is a kind of NE specific marker, but
as you showed in the western, 22RV1 cell
lines also expressed that marker, but 22RV1 is not
a kind of NEPC model.
Why does it express NE markers as you said?
So,
22RV1 is a typical CRPC cell line. But in some
conditions, 22RV1 also can express the NE markers,
especially in the androgen-deprivation conditions.
So I know it's not a NEPC cell line.
Okay. Whatever. And your target,
KDM5B and the SOX9, it also have
expression in some adenocarcinoma cell lines like
LNCaP, C4-2 or something. What are they doing?
Okay. So-
Why? Yeah.
Okay. So SOX9 is a transcription factor.
So the wet leads have a very strong evidence
SOX9 is... correlated with AR inhibitor
resistance and also the stem-like
characteristics in the prostate cancer cells, but they don't have
very strong evidence show the SOX9 is related
to the NEPC development. That's-
But you said the SOX9 drives the neuroendocrine in
your project.
So this is a
very important question. So we
did show the SOX9 is in correlated with
other like established
RB1 or TP53 maybe contributed to the
NEPC development.
So currently, we don't have directly evidence to confirm
SOX9 really contribute. The reason is
we always express SOX9 in the LNCaP cells,
but all expressed SOX9 alone doesn't result in
NE differentiations. That's why I said maybe
in parallel with other signaling pathway to induce the
NE development.
Sorry, Chair. Can I still ask the
questions or there's-
You still can ask.
Okay. Sorry.
Just very curious.
In your OE model,
after the treatment of the CSS in your
LNCaP OE model, your target even goes up.
Does it mean every kind of adenocarcinoma cells after the
ADT treatment will go to NEPC?
If it's
very long, probably most androgen-sensitive cells can
go to the NEPC, especially LNCaP.
But the incidence of NEPC is only 15%
to 5% around the world.
I know. That's true, but most cell line androgen system, at least
to my best knowledge, like LNCaP, C4-2B, a lot
of if you really culture either in the AR inhibitor as in
luteinized or remove androgen signaling for a long time, half year, one year,
they will
really resistant. At the very beginning, most of you are dying, but
some cells survival. After one year or at least half year,
they really show that we call it NE-like morphology.
The NE marker is increased, but-
Yeah. They're NE-like, but are they the therapy-induced
NEPC or just a CRPC with NE phenotype?
This is, we just call NEPC-like cell line.
Okay.
Yeah.
No further questions.
I know, because in the human, it's only 20%, but all the other
AR sensitive cell line could be do this.
And we have one last question.
Yep, sure. Nadine Mogul from LightHorse Therapeutics.
Did you look at ASCL1 expression in any of your models?
I'm curious to see whether or not that was also dependent on KDM5B.
And then related to that,
have you looked at, to see any phenotypes in small cell lung cancer that has
ASCL1 in it?
No. We are working in the single RNA seq to look for
the data to if they correlate with other signaling pathways.
Thank you so much.
Now, our next speaker is Sarah-Jane Thursby from Johns Hopkins
University, who is going to talk about DNA methylation and aging.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for the opportunity to the organizers for allowing me to speak today.
I would like to talk to you today about my project entitled "Promoter Methylation
Gains in Aging and Cancer Are Independent of Replication."
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
There are
multiple
levels of chromatin remodelers that exist to
mediate DNA methylation,
for example, in aging and colon cancer.
If we take young wild-type organoids, we culture them for 12 to 14
months, they become old wild-type organoids.
We induce a BRF600E mutation. Within two weeks, they will become a colon
cancer. If we take young wild-type organoids, culture them
with the BRF600E mutation for five months, they will also become a colon
cancer. We can short-circuit this process if we knock out these
four key genes,
induce a BRF mutation, and then within two weeks, they will become a colon cancer.
And what's interesting about all of these models is they all
share a high degree of DNA methylation
alterations. So this begets the following questions.
What are the dynamics of DNA methylation during early tumorigenesis?
Are the DNA methylation changes induced by oncogenic stress?
And are the DNA methylation changes due to cell division?
To examine this, we follow the following experimental outline.
From the mice, we take its colon, we develop it into organoids, and
then we induce the BRF600E mutation.
And then monthly for five months, we disassociate the organoid into single
cells, grow the single cell into the single organoid, pick the single organoid,
and do a single organoid WGBS. Because this is a single organoid,
we need to alter the WGBS library prep a little bit.
In order to do this, we use whole genome amplification that is
multime-based, using multiple displacement amplification to
combat primer bias and amplification bias.
If we look at the resulting data, what we can observe is that the control
lineage exhibits a stepwise divergence from one to five months.
The BRF lineage, however, exhibits epigenetic drift, followed by
clonal convergence or takeover at the five months.
Interestingly, if we compare global CPG
methylationBetween control and BRAF V600E
clones,
we do not see any global DNA methylation changes,
indicating that BRAF V600E does not acutely induce DNA
methylation changes in our colon organoids.
If we look at our differential methylation, what we observe is areas
without CGI tend to lose methylation.
Areas with CGI tend to gain methylation.
This is consistent with the literature.
If we look at the percentage of overlap between the
two lineages in terms of gain or in terms of loss, there is very little
overlap in terms of the sites affected.
However, if I was to map those specific CpG sites to their
associated
genomic elements, for example, promoter with CGI, promoter without
CGI, what we observe is that there is a vast overlap
in areas affected. To investigate this further, we looked
at our single-cell RNA seq. We did a pseudobulk analysis,
and we enriched for unique transcription factors in those differentially
methylated sites. What we observed is that control lineage
transcription factors are enriched for stress or viral-related
pathways. But those are
not present in the BRAF V600E unique
transcription factors. Instead, we have an enrichment for
cancer-related transcription factors.
So this indicates some sort of
invasion strategy in the BRAF V600E
lineage, but that has to be further investigated.
So far, I've talked to you about the one-month and the five-month comparison.
However, I also have a two-month, a three-month, and a four-month comparison.
In order to investigate whether our methylation gains were
stochastic or formed any sort of trajectory,
we looked at bivalent CGI elements, and we also looked at
non-CGI elements. Bivalent because they have been shown to gain as a function of
replication, and non-CGI because they have been shown to lose as a function of
replication.
What we observe is that the BRAF and the control lineage
exhibit very similar trajectories across the five months.
We do not see an accelerated trajectory in the BRAF lineage,
which would have been expected if those DNA methylation gains were a function
of replication. However, we do see an accelerated
trajectory in the BRAF lineage in non-CGI sites,
indicating that the losses in
DNA methylation are a function of replication.
If we look at this in external datasets, for example, in this
transformation model, where you have early passage cells
that are then serially transfected with different proliferative
agents, what you observe is median methylation remains constant no
matter how many proliferative agents are added.
And then if you look at the non-CGI sites in this particular experiment,
what you observe is a downward trajectory in terms of DNA methylation,
indicating, again, that your gains in methylation at your bivalently marked
promoters are not a function of replication,
but your non-CGI losses are a function of replication.
You can see this pattern again in the replication inhibition model.
Again, publicly available data. They used
mitomycin C to block mitosis. You can observe that the control and the
mitomycin C lineages have very similar trajectories.
And then if we look at the solo WCDW sites,
which are known to lose methylation as a function of replication, what you can
observe is that methylation loss is attenuated
in comparison to the control. Again, backing up our
finding that promoter methylation gains are independent of replication,
but losses are not.
Then if we look at in vivo tCGI data
from colon cancer, what we observe is while the colon
cancer starts at a higher point, it gains
methylation at a trajectory that's very similar to the healthy.
Then if we look at solo WCDW sites, what we
observe is that the healthy loses methylation as a
function of age, but the colon cancer
loses methylation up to a point where there's no more methylation to be
lost.
So in conclusion, the BRAF V600E mutation does not cause
acute or rapid changes in DNA methylation.
DNA methylation changes that do occur, occur at different sites that
map to the same genomic elements. Transcription factor profiles
of the BRAF lineage exhibit a strong relationship with colon
carcinogenesis, but some via VEID, stress or viral-related
pathways present in the control lineage and
gains in DNA methylation in promoters in both lineages
are replication independent.
Thank you very much for this opportunity, and I'd be happy to take any
questions.
Thank you for a great talk. Now the floor is open for discussion and questions.
Okay. I will start. The promoter DNA methylation that is
distinct from replication, is that unique to colon cancer?
So far it is unique to colon cancer.
I have not tested it in any other cancer, but my
expectation would be what we would find a similar pattern, especially for
those cancers that exhibit CpG island
hypermethylator phenotype.
And were you surprised by the BRAF data that did not induce-
Yes.
Yeah.
Yes, I have checked it many times.
How can you explain that?
For example,
in the literature, a lot of the BRAF studies, they use
already cancer samples, whereas ours are pre-cancers.
Or they use, for example, a cancer sample in which they have corrected
using CRISPR, the BRAF mutation.
So our pre-cancer samples,
they highlight a different part of the carcinogenic
trajectory, and that's why I think we're getting our results.
Yes?
Thank you. Really interesting work. Chiara Herzler from King's College London.
I was curious,
because you looked at the promoter methylation and
replication, did you also ever check mitotic clocks like the EpiTOC clock?
Yes.
What was the finding there?
The finding in EpiTOC clock was very
similar.
I find replication-based clocks kind of confusing.
But yes, it backed up our results.
Hi. Ace from UBC, Canada. Just have a general question.
For your introduction, like the young organoid and
mature or adult organoid, what is a definite
morphological or molecular
features for you to differentiate?
For example, the old wild-type organoid would be more likely to
be senescent, excrete the senescence-associated phenotype.
The young wild-type organoid would have
greater budding efficiency.
Right. Thanks.
And do you have a good correlation of the data in organoids relative to
patients' data? I know you did some comparison with TCGA.
Yeah. There is a good correlation between our organoids and between TCGA.
Mm-hmm.
With that, let us thank the speaker.
So our next speaker is Richa Singh from Weill
Cornell Medicine, and she's going to talk about cooperation
of DNMT and EZH2 in prostate cancer.
And she received award in
this conference, so congratulations. Richa, great job.
Thank you. Okay, so good afternoon, everyone.
I would be talking about, the cooperativity between DNA methylation and
EZH2 activity that drives the neuroendocrine phenotype in advanced prostate
cancer.
So I won't dwell too much on the disease since it has already been
beautifully covered by previous speakers.
But
what I would like to say is,
we know already that the prostate cancer progresses through multiple stages,
where the adenocarcinoma
are initially formed, which are androgen-driven and AR positive.
They express luminal and epithelial markers, and upon prolonged androgen
deprivation therapy, many of them progress to an androgen-independent state,
which is an AR negative state. And they
express neuroendocrine markers here.
Now, evidences from clinical samples have shown that
the two subtypes, the prostate adenocarcinoma, and the neuroendocrine prostate
cancer, are genomically very similar.
But they differ epigenetically and transcriptionally,
suggesting that maybe
this epigenomic reprogramming is the major driving feature
of this lineage plasticity that happens in these aggressive prostate
adenocarcinoma. We also know from these clinical samples that DNA
methylation profile alone can segregate these patient
tumors into different clusters that resemble their histological subtypes.
So this led us to question
what establishes this DNA methylome landscape in
NEPC.
So for this, we took advantage of a published mouse model, which is an
NEPC mouse model. It has an N-myc
overexpression with p10 and Rb1 colos under probasin Cre.
And these mouse model develop an adenocarcinoma
histology. And as they age, they form
neuroendocrine tumor foci in them.
These adenocarcinoma and neuroendocrine tumor foci
are histologically and molecularly similar to that of
patient tumors of CRPC and NEPC.
Now, upon comparing the DNA methylome of the adenocarcinoma and
the NEPC tumors from this mouse model, we
observed that there was a drastic shift in the DNA methylome
profile.
So much so that
the differentially methylated regions from
this comparison of NEPC versus prostate
adenocarcinoma could segregate an independent cohort of
patient tumors into clusters that resemble the
histological subtypes again.
So we then wanted to know what genes are associated with these DMRs, and we
observed that most of the hypomethylated DMRs are
indeed enriched at the PRC2 targets that is
responsible for catalyzing the H3K27 trimethylation,
which is an repressive histone mark.
Now, based on studies from embryonic stem cell, we
know that
the loss of activity of DNA
methylators and
PRC2 complex can redirect the activity of each other.
So this led us to a hypothesis,
whether there is a potential interplay between
H3K27 trimethylation and DNA methylation during
lineage plasticity in these cancer.
So before this, we wanted to check the expression of these regulators and
catalyzers of DNA methylation and H3K27 trimethylation,
and we observed that across a mouse model and patient-derived
organoids, we do see a robust expression of these
DNA methylators and EZH2, which is the
catalytic subunit of PRC2 complex.
Now moving forward, we first wanted to see how the
H3K27 trimethylation is altered as the tumor
progresses from adenocarcinoma to NEPC.
So for this, we again took advantage of a PRM mouse model, and
we saw a drastic shift or redistribution of H3K27
trimethylation as the tumor progresses to
NEPC.We also additionally
observed that
there was an enrichment of H3K27 trimethylation at the
hypomethylated DMRs in the NEPC tumors compared to the
adenocarcinoma tumors.
We also observed this
phenotype, or this observation was also seen at the
hypomethylated DMRs from the patient tumors in the patient-derived organoids
as well as patient tumors again.
Now since all of the previous findings was based on the bisulfite sequencing data,
we wanted to extend this observation
in a different methylome capture based methodology.
So for this, we took advantage of array-based
methylome data from a collaborator lab, and we again see the
same thing, which is H3K27 trimethylation was more
enriched at the hypomethylated DMRs in NEPC
compared to the adenocarcinoma.
Now we wanted to know what happens with the neuron-related genes and the luminal
genes, and we observed that the neuron-related
genes or the neuroendocrine markers, they have an enrichment
of H3K27 trimethylation and DNA methylation in
the prostate adenocarcinomas. Whereas
the AR signaling genes and the luminal markers have an
enrichment of DNA methylation and H3K27
trimethylation in the NEPC tumors.
Suggesting that perhaps these genes were more repressed in the prostate
adenocarcinoma and NEPC state, respectively.
So we then wanted to see what happens with the regulation
of these catalyzers and whether perturbing one can
alter the activity of the other.
So for this, we first deleted EZH2,
which is the catalytic subunit of PRC2 complex in an NEPC
model.
And for this, we generated a mouse model, which we named as PRNE,
where we introduced an EZH2 allele in a previously published
PRN model.
And this model had an overall survival similar
to that of the PRN and was able to generate
NEPC tumors,
which were negative for EZH2 and H3K27
trimethylation.
Now, molecularly, we
observed that this model had an increase
in NEPC signature score, compared to the
tumors which had an expression of EZH2.
So we then wanted to compare the DNA methylation of this EZH2 deleted
NEPC tumor,
with that of EZH2 expressing tumors.
And we observed a drastic change in DNA methylome landscape
here.
We also observed these changes happening at the PRN defined clinically
relevant DMRs that I previously mentioned.
We also observed
this methylation change when we inhibited EZH2 in an NEPC
patient-derived organoid here.
And across both our mouse model and patient-derived
NEPC model, we observed a similar enrichment of
hypomethylated regions at the-- Sorry
hypermethylated regions at the promoters of
both the models.
We then wanted to explore how this methylation
change can affect the downstream transcription.
So we compared it with the transcriptional profile, and we
observed that, as we would have also expected, since we
got the NEPC signature score to be high, we
expected hypomethylation to be more
enriched at the
neuron-related genes, and that is what we observed here.
We also observed an overlap of these
acquired differentially methylated regions at the previously found
H3K27 trimethylation peaks,
for some of the neuron-related genes.
Suggesting that the
H3K27 trimethylation was
perhaps compensated by DNA methylation in the NEPC
model.
We also observed
transcriptional changes in concordance with the DNA methylome
changes in the NEPC
model, which were deleted with EZH2.
So we then wanted to explore what happens if DNMT1 is
deleted
here in an NEPC model. And for this, we generated
a
DNMT1 deleted model in an NEPC patient-derived organoid.
And we did indeed see a redistribution of H3K27
trimethylation here.
Interestingly, contrary to EZH2 deletion, we observed
that the neuron-related genes here, in this case, acquired
more of H3K27 trimethylation leading to a downregulation
of the neuron-related genes.
We also observed an enrichment of the
H3K27 trimethylation at the bivalently marked
genes and at the PRC2 target genes upon the knockdown of
TNMT in an NEPC model.
We wanted to validate this with pharmacological perturbation.
So for this, we used an NEPC xenograft model, which was available
in
our lab, and we treated the model with decitabine.
That is a DNMT inhibitor for a week in vivo.
And
we again saw a redistribution of H3K27 trimethylation here, similar to
that of EZH2-- Sorry, DNMT
deletion.Similar to
DNMT1 deletion, upon inhibition of DNMT, we
saw an enrichment of H3K27 trimethylation and
decrease at H3K4 trimethylation at these bivalent
peaks, which are active histone marks.
Now, we also wanted to expand this further in other models.
So we did a perturbation of DNMT1 in an
adenocarcinoma model this time. And here
too, H3K27 trimethylation was redistributed drastically.
But
contrary to the NEPC model, in this case, we saw an
upregulation of the neuron-related genes with depletion of H3K27
trimethylation upon deletion of DNMT1.
For the bivalent Li mark genes as well, we saw a
depletion of H3K27 trimethylation
leading to an upregulation of these genes.
So
with this, I would like to conclude
and say that we do establish
that there was a crosstalk between DNMT and
EZH2 during lineage plasticity in advanced prostate cancer.
However, the regulation or
perturbing the regulators of these
repressive mechanisms do differ functionally
specific to the disease state, basically.
So this is what we found. And with this, I would like to conclude and
thank our mentors on the project, Dr. Rickman and Dr. Beltran.
And this work was done in collaboration with Balaji.
And
I would also like to thank all our other collaborators and lab members, and
also our funding sources, especially DoD and EUA, for funding this project.
And I would be happy to take any questions now.
Thank you so much for a wonderful talk.
Now it is open for discussion. Please state your name and
university.
Hi. John DeSisto from University of Colorado.
Very nice work. I'm curious about
the interplay, if you will, between the
methyltransferase loss and then the gain of
H3K27 trimethyl kind of going in the different
directions transcriptionally.
One way to interpret that, I suppose, would be that the DNA
methyltransferase loss is opening up chromatin generally, and
then the H3K27 trimethyl is
coming in more particularly on a certain set of genes.
Do you think of it that way? And if you do, do you have any
odd ideas about the pathways that are implicated?
Yeah. So I definitely think that there is some physical hindrance,
and as soon as the DNMTs are dislodged or they are lost,
PRC2 complex can come up and start being
at those locations. Right? So yeah, I think I
agree with the hypothesis there that dislodging or freeing
up the space is taken up by the PRC2 complex there.
Yeah. I think it is difficult to explain the other way around why
loss of EZH2 is getting compensated by
DNMT, but more to study on this. This
was very preliminary stage study.
Yeah. It looks like you have several years of work ahead of you if you decide to
pursue it.
All right.
Great work. Hari Ishwar from Hopkins.
Two questions. One is,
maybe I got confused. I didn't get this.
So when you knock out DNMT1 or down-regulate DNMT1.
Sorry, down-regulates EZH2, methylation
increases in the same regions where the neuroendocrine promoters
are. Right? And which were previously
K27 marked. Now they are methylation marked.
So what happens to expression?
Yeah.
How does the phenotype change still?
Yeah. So the four or five genes which I've shown in the track,
some of those are neuron-related genes, but
not all of them. And
the expression was still
there in that NEPC EZH2 wild-type model.
But when we deleted EZH2, some of those genes, such as
FOXA2, got even more upregulated now because
there was no DNA methylation happening.
But it is-
There wasn't any H3K27 trimethylation happening, but there was still some
hypomethylation. So I showed both the tracks there for
FOXA2 and so.
And any idea, like during the
spontaneous generation of NEPC, how does the switch occur
between DNMT1-regulated to EZH2-regulated?
Is it a cell of origin that is what is the determinant
or-
So-
-approaching
... the fact that perturbing DNMT1
in different cell state did end up doing different
things functionally downstream.
As in, in one case, in CRPC, we saw an upregulation of neuron-related
genes. But in an NEPC model, we see a
downregulation of the neuron-related genes.
I definitely think that the role of these regulators are
cell state specific.
But
when I say cell state specific, it can also be some specifiers
associated with that cell state, which is actually
directing the specificity of these regulators.
So
there may be some specific co-factors associated, what I think.
Thank you.
Hi. Ace from UBC Canada. I have a question regarding
that you mentioned DNMT1 EZH2 interplay in the terminal
NEPC, and you also manipulate one
gene to kind of affect the entire NEPC development.
My question is,
in the natural condition of NEPC development, do you think these
two always interplay at different stages
or one work first and the other one work after?
I think it is sequential more than working together, because had it
been working together, we would have seen them also
interacting or locating at the same place in
NEPC model. So it was the hypomethylation
that was more enriched with H3K27 trimethylation.
So maybe one has dislodged from a place and then the other has come up.
So it is more like a sequential kind of a thing, maybe.
All right.
And not working together simultaneously at the same spot.
Thanks.
Hi. I enjoyed your talk. My question is, have you seen some
clinical examples since in your study you knocked
out EZH2 and saw the DNA
methylation landscape change? Have you seen any clinical examples of
EZH2 either not being present at the neuroendocrine
stage or in some patients versus others?
Because several studies have shown the involvement of EZH2 in
that transition to neuroendocrine.
No, I think EZH2 is very highly expressed in NEPC.
I don't
really know of any NEPC tumor which is absent of
EZH2.
So do you think that if
it was to be targeted, say, at the disease stage, if
that would cause a change or a shift in
methylation that could be taken advantage of maybe
through another treatment modality?
So the question, if it's EZH2 targeted before the NEPC state is formed
or?
Or at the NEPC state.
So at the NEPC state, if we target EZH2, it is
developing more aggressive NEPC.
So that is definitely not helping because maybe it is getting compensated by the
methylation.
But before. So you're saying if you target it before.
So before could be tried.
Not sure. We haven't done it in our hands, so.
Great. Thanks so much.
Our next speaker is Joshua Luepe from Van
Andel Institute, and he's going to talk about DNA
methyltransferase 1 and its application in cancer
therapy.
Hi.
I'd like to thank the organizers for giving me this chance to share my work
with you all.
I'm Joshua, and I'll be talking today about
targeting the ubiquitin reading function of DNMT1 as a
next generation approach for epigenetic cancer
therapy.
Aberrant or abnormal DNA methylation is mediated
through DNA methyltransferases,
and this abnormal DNA methylation is one of the
most consistent and functionally important epigenetic
alterations in cancer.
And
some of its effect include tumor suppressor gene silencing,
as well as oncogene silencing.
It also results in hypomethylation of these
oncogenic regions, resulting in genomic instability.
This effect is not only localized, but it impacts
nearly all the hallmarks of
cancers, from sustaining proliferative
signaling to evading growth suppressors to even immune
modulation. So for this reason, DNA
methyltransferase inhibitors are developed to clinically
manage cancers.
Agents such as 5-Azacytidine and
Decitabine are the most clinically advanced
epigenetic drugs currently. And despite their successes
in hematological
cancers, they do have
limitations, especially or in particular with solid tumors.
And
their limitations include the fact that they have a short half-life,
mainly because of cytidine deaminase that is able to
inactivate them. They're also replication
dependent. And then there's the issue of dose limiting toxicities.
The mechanism of action of these drugs requires
chromatin targeting of DNA methyltransferases.
And for DNMT1, it involves the E3
ligase UHRF1.
DNMT1 relies on this co-factor, UHRF1,
in order to carry out faithful methylation inheritance.
As you can see from this figure on the left, in the absence of
UHRF1, there is a global reduction in DNA methylation.
Also, DNMT1 is unable to localize to
replicating foci in the absence of UHRF1.
This suggests that DNMT1 targeting to chromatin
is replication coupled and also UHRF1
dependent. So then the question is: how does UHRF1 carry out
this process of targeting DNMT1 to
chromatin?
Through multivalent interactions that UHRF1 has with DNA
and histone H3, it is
targeted to newly replicated DNA, where through
its ring finger domain, it's able to write the
ubiquitin marks on the histone H3 tails.
DNMT1 then recognizes these ubiquitin marks through
its ubiquitin interacting motifs that are located or embedded
within its RFTS domain.Once this happens,
DNMT1 becomes recruited, and it's able to
lay or write the methylation marks on the daughter strand.
So the UIMs or the ubiquitin interacting motifs of
DNMT1, therefore present to us a novel way of
targeting DNMT1.
So we asked the question,
could the ubiquitin interacting motif of DNMT1
be responsible for the DNA methylation maintenance function of
DNMT1? So to answer this question, we built a
genetic complementation system where we could
sustain a colorectal cancer cell in the absence of
key functional domains of DNMT1. So what we basically
did was to mutate the catalytic domain and
also the UIM domains, and then we compared them.
And in vitro assays that we carried out in our
lab show that the UIM is unable to
bind
ubiquitinated nucleosomes, even though it was able to retain
its catalytic activity. And when we measured the
DNA methylation profile from the
mutated
UIMs, we found that the loss of methylation
with the UIM mutant is comparable or
identical to DNMT1 being knocked down or they're
catalytically dead. So from this, we also performed
cell-based assays. We did clonogenic assays as well as
IncuCyte
outgrowth assays. And we also found that in the absence of a
functional ubiquitin interacting motif, cell viability is
also hampered in a similar way as what we see with the catalytically
dead or DNMT1 being knocked down. So from this, we concluded that
DNMT1's ubiquitin reading function is essential for DNA
methylation and also the viability of cancer cells.
Next, we then asked, transcriptionally, what happens when this
UIM is non-functional?
And then we compared that with DNMT1 knockdown, as well as the
catalytically dead. And we found there were significant
overlaps between these, and this is
because, importantly, what we see is that these genes are
upregulated, and when we looked at their promoters, we
see that they are losing DNA methylation, which is
consistent with what I just showed on the previous slide, that the UIMs
are needed for the DNA methylation function of
DNMT1. So we also looked at, globally, which
pathways are being changed as a result of a non-functional
ubiquitin interacting motif of DNMT1.
And we do see upregulation of viral mimicry associated
hallmarks and a downregulation of oncogenic transmitomic
pathways. And these pathways are also
consistent with what we observe with decitabine or the
current FDA-approved DNMTis.
So from this, we actually
concluded that the DNMT1 ubiquitin reader disruption is
able to recapitulate the effects of
DNMTis. So this presents us with a novel way
of targeting DNMT1. So this motivated
us to perform two screens. The first was a natural
product and
macrocyclic compound screen, which we did in
collaboration with the University of Michigan Center for Chemical
Genomics. And from this screen, we identified a natural product
extract with afetinib Pharmaco four as a hit.
We also did a biologic screen where we used
de novo design tools to engineer small protein
binders that could actually competitively bind to the
UIMs of DNMT1 to prevent its ubiquitin reading
activity. And what we found from the preliminary screens was
we're able to identify a low nanomolar binder, which is able
to inhibit DNMT1's ubiquitin reading function.
And we are excited about these particular binders, and we're looking
forward to
pursue these as a novel way of targeting DNMT1.
So to sum up my talk, the methyltransferase activity of
DNMT1 in human cancer cells is completely dependent on its ability
to read ubiquitin activity. And this ubiquitin
reading activity is also essential for the viability of these cancer cells.
And when it is disrupted, we see a strong hypomethylation,
activation of immune pathways, and a suppression of oncogenic signaling
pathways. And I've also shown you evidence that the
UIM motif or the ubiquitin reading activity of DNMT1 is
druggable.
I would like to acknowledge, first of all, my mentor, Professor Scott
Rotbart from VAI, who's been very phenomenal and an
excellent PI, who guided the direction of this project.
Also to thank the members of the Rothbart lab, our collaborators.
The Worden lab helped with the design of the de novo binders.
The natural product and macrocyclic screens were done in
collaboration with the University of Michigan Center for Chemical Genomics.
I thank my IDT team, support from the Postdoctoral Affairs Office of
VAI, and then the Genomics Core. None of this would have been possible
without funding, and I'd like to thank these funding
sources and also to mention that I am a postdoc within the
Concept Genetics Training Program at the Van Andel Institute, which
we consider it to be one of the best places to be trained as a
postdoc. So if anybody's looking for a postdoc, please reach
out to the VAI Institute. You'll get the best training.
So
I'm happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Thank you, Joshua, for a great talk.
Now we open to discussions and questions.So I can
start. This novel way of targeting DNMT1, how can it
be superior to the current target of therapies that we have for DNMT1,
and how does it look in mouse models, if you have done those
experiments?
Okay.
Let me start with the mouse models.
So the mouse models is one thing we are now looking to
start working on. We've applied for funding for that.
So that is something we have plans for.
And currently, we are testing these binders in
cell lines to see how it engages DNMT1, and whether it's able to
recapitulate what we've observed with the genetic manipulation of the
UIM domains. So how is this better than the
current DNMTis? For one,
what we've observed is that these are not replication-dependent.
Because the current DNMTis all need replication,
the DNA methyltransferases, to actually
be recruited to chromatin during replication for them to
carry out their functions. With this, all we're
inhibiting is the ability to recruit DNMT1 to chromatin.
So if we're able to
prevent that from happening, we will not need the replication
ability. And another issue with requiring replication is it
results in DNA damage, which can lead to a lot of off-target effects.
So we're still trying to refine these binders.
We've computationally generated them, and so we've used the one that came out
as a hit as the basis to iterate and get more
binders, which we're then going to screen till we get one that is
totally or completely refined to actually enable efficient
binding to DNMT1. Yes.
Great. Thank you. Yes?
Hi, Nadeem Moghal from LightHorse Therapeutics.
From your RNA seq data, you seem to show data that there was a set of
genes that was regulated by the knockdown of the protein, but not when you have the
affecting the catalytic activity.
Mm-hmm.
Can you comment on what might be known about that biology and if that's also
relevant to cancer growth?
For now, we don't know anything. We're still doing assays to actually
confirm the biology of these genes that we have.
Yeah, this is the preliminary data.
It's about
six weeks to a month old. But we're still working on stuff. Yeah, so.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Steve?
So, hi. I know this gentleman well, and he knows me.
Because with other work that the Rothbart lab does-
Yes
... our group collaborates.
Yeah.
I think it's really important because there have been some
mysteries about some of the previous talks and the questions that come up.
Yeah.
Maybe quickly try to resolve this, and I think he'll agree.
The UHRF1 is a critical gene. That is the master gene for
determining DNA methylation. You get rid of it, and that's gone.
But it is the gene that also takes the DNA methyltransferases
to the dance.
Yes.
And in this case, it recognizes also another repressive mark.
Mm-hmm.
Which is H3K9 di- and tri-methyl.
Methyl. Yes.
Now, the difference in your ligase part in this beautiful work is, and
I think I understand this correct, it doesn't hit CpG rich sites when
you do this.
Yes.
But the other mark hits CpG rich sites.
And it's the islands of promoter CpG island genes that are the
hundreds of tumor suppressor genes that you upregulate as well.
Whether yours is additive or not, or whether they're not
together is not known. But that was what we were trying to ask the
previous speaker to you. Did you see upregulation of
specific
tumor suppressor genes? And you've got to have that CpG rich loci in
promoters. In some, they are cancer specific enhancer
hypermethylation. So I hope... It's a lot to think about.
Yes.
But you had a beautiful slide on that.
This is very location dependent.
Indeed.
It depends on where you query-
Yeah
... with what you've done.
Yes.
So I hope people will think about that. And it's in the literature.
The papers are there to take a look. Thanks.
Thank you.
It was a beautiful talk.
And you really... It's great work.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. Let us all thank Joshua for a great talk.
Our next speaker is Shilpa Dave from MD
Anderson, who is going to talk about role of
KDM2A in esophageal progression.
Hi. Thank you all, and thank you organizers for providing me this
opportunity to present our work. This is just a preliminary work
that I'm
going to present today. And it's about
the KDM2A driven epigenetic reprogramming that
promotes the Barrett esophagus to
adenocarcinoma. I have nothing to disclose.
So esophageal adenocarcinoma is a
very lethal GI cancer since it has a
poor survival. And the precursor of
EAC is a Barrett esophagus, which is,
when as you see here, it is replaced by the
columnar epithelium and goblet cells,
due to chronic injury like inflammation or
acid reflux. And histologically then it
progresses to low-grade dysplasia, high-grade dysplasia,
and then finally to esophageal
adenocarcinoma.
So
many evidences have shown that epigenetic
plasticity shapes this disease progressions,
due to DNA methylation changes occurring early in the Barrett,
and then enhancer activation... is increased,
and then the tumor heterogeneity happens.
This enhancer reprogramming drives the oncogenic transcriptions,
and then chronic injury, inflammation, and genetic
changes also
promote this tumor heterogeneity.
The missing link is what is the
main driver or a regulator for this,
in terms of epigenetic regulator,
that increases this enhancer activation and
chromosome stability,
which transitions this metaplasia of this chromatin
state to this malignant metaplasia.
And if there is a need of some driver which can be
drugable, which can be epigenetic driver too.
So looking for the different, we just looked at the
TCGA database for esophageal adenocarcinoma and
looked into different histone demethylases, among which we
found KDM2A, which is a histone
demethylase. It demethylases
H3K36me2, and it has a
Jumonji C
domain, and it was the most highly amplified
in this among all the demethylases in esophageal
adenocarcinoma patients.
And to validate our finding from TCDA, we
have our own patient cohort, and we
tested, checked the expression of KDM2A
from Barrett to low-grade dysplasia and till EAC,
which is
very advanced metastatic EAC stage, which is a diffuse type.
And to our surprise, KDM2A was
found to be increased and had a
trend, but not very significant.
But it has a trend of showing increase from Barrett to esophageal
adenocarcinoma.
So we think that KDM2A initiates this
progression of Barrett to EAC. Not all Barrett
progress to EAC, so that is also another challenge.
So we think maybe genetic mutations alone are not enough.
So there should be some epigenetic link which can lead to
this progression.
And we, again, since KDM2A is the demethylase, so
we checked the
KDM2A expression also leads to decrease of
H3K36me2 in Barrett till
EAC levels. So it very well correlates too in the
patient samples. These are all human EAC patient samples.
To further, this is just to show what cohort we use
to do our special transcriptomic data.
So that's using COSMIC. And we use different
patient samples in a TME, and to see the
cellular
state, especially in each stages of disease
progression.
Here you can see the Barrett
tumors are very well organized,
and better than the EAC tumor heterogeneity.
We found different cell clusters of epithelial
cluster as well as stromal clusters, and they show a clear
distinct pattern for each
disease state, from Barrett, EAC to LGD.
Particularly when we looked into the cell type per tissue,
you can see we found an increase of macrophage and
CAF cells in EAC as compared to Barrett.
And we found when epithelial,
different types of epithelial state two,
especially from low-grade dysplasia to esophageal
adenocarcinoma, which was not found in the Barrett.
So to further validate this epithelial one and
epithelial two, with this KDM2A
status was high in these samples. We think
that KDM2A initiates this Barrett
into two epithelial cell states,
where you can see this SPINK1 and PSCA, which are the secretory
ligand or stemness markers, were
high in this epithelial one state
when we compared Barrett to EAC. And since the
epithelial two was not found in Barrett, so we just compared it with
the EAC to LGD, where we see that all the
oncogenic signaling, which were amplified in epithelial two
markers.
Further to compare whether the KDM2A, we also
went back to our TCGA dataset and found that
KDM2A high levels had poor prognosis, and
it very well correlates with the different oncogenic
signalings and showing like HER2, MYC, and
EGFR.
And to further validate, wanted to
understand this disease modeling in some system that
not using human patient samples and tissues all the time and doing
COSMIC. We tried to
create a model, which is esophageal organoid models
using the Barrett esophageal organoids from the patient
and EAC patients.
So this is
just a published data we just published earlier,
showing that Barrett cells and EAC cells show the same
morphology from the primary tumor.
And it showed KDM2A, PSC1, SPINK1, and
HERB2 expressions were high in EAC
cells.So,
further we wanted to build a PDO bank of
patients with high and low KDM2A. So we
are trying to generate Barrett organoids with--
I'm just showing one example with both Barrett and
esophageal adenocarcinoma organoids with high KDM2A.
But we have also trying to get more organoids with low
KDM2A, and we'll be comparing it too.
So, as you can see here, K36me2 is going
down, and K27 acetylation, which is an enhancer mark,
is going up,
along with the other oncogenic signaling, such as
FING1, PSCA, and MYC.
So
we wanted to also overexpress KDM2A in normal
esophageal cells, and we use HET-1A,
which is a normal esophageal cell.
And as you can see, KDM2A is overexpressed and showing
similar pattern. It's increasing all
target genes when you overexpress KDM2A in normal
cells.
So,
to understand the epigenetic
impact, we did ATAC-seq of same HET-1 cells with the
KDM2A overexpression. And you see there is a distinct
open chromatin pattern in the KDM2A
overexpression, and distinct features showed
increased regulatory
programs. And when we checked the MYC oncogene loci,
you see there is an open chromatin in MYC with the KDM2A
overexpression as compared to the wild type.
And we also have other oncogenic signalings also
showing open chromatin. So more of the increased signalings are
in secretory and oncogenic pattern.
And we are still performing CUT&RUN and other single-cell
ATAC-seq.
So finally, this is
just a hypothetical model where we think that
low KDM2A will have high H3K36, which
is a active mark, and you will have a stable chromatin.
When KDM2A is initiated at early stage of
Barrett, there is a chromatin reprogramming happening,
which will increase this K27 acetylation.
It's an enhancer-driven transcriptional activation, and
will create a two different types of epithelial program.
One is the epithelial secretory niche, which will have the
secretory signaling increased. And
another cell type will be highly
proliferative, which has a oncogenic
signaling activation. So this both cell
type may coexist in a EAC tumor state,
and this both will increase the heterogeneity of tumor
types and tumor progression. So from Barrett to
EAC, maybe the KDM2A act as a
initiator or a regulator, which is sustained
from all the disease stage.
And I would like to acknowledge all my lab members, especially Li
Yong and Ariana. They
established this
Barrett esophageal organoids. Our team,
clinical team, Dr. Ajani, and all collaborators, and funding
support. And thank you.
Thank you so much. The floor is now open to discussion.
And I probably have a first question.
Did you show, I don't know, maybe ChIP-seq data
demonstrating that KDM2A is bound to your targets like
MYC?
Yeah, that is what we are working on.
And we have done CUT&RUN and like
KDM2A in HET-1 cells, but we are now trying to look into the
more organoids and human
cell lines.
Okay. Sounds good. Great.
And probably another question from me.
You mentioned
histone acetylation, but you didn't quite show the data.
Can you tell us a little bit more about your-
Yeah. Acetylation mark in the organoids, I have shown it's increased, and we
have performed CUT&RUN, which I did not,
due to the time limit, I'm not showing all data.
But we have that,
showing that CUT&RUN for K27 acetylation.
We also did some special epigenomics thing
just to see whether really you can see
these marks enhance in that particular cell state.
Yeah.
And single-cell ATAC-seq we are performing.
So maybe single-cell RNA-seq, special transcriptomics, and special
epigenomics we are trying to incorporate.
It's a little challenge, but we are trying to perform those kind of
assay and see the cellular state really shows
particular activation mark in that particular tumor state.
Mm-hmm.
I also have a question. Do you know any of the transcription factors that crosstalk
with KDM2A in the
transfer from-
Yeah.
-
the adenocarcinoma?
So that is the motif analysis. We are going to do it in
organoids.
But in HET-1A, we found certain transcription
factors, but they're not related
to this esophageal adenocarcinoma.
So it's like SOX2 and
SOX4 and something like that, but not that related.
So I'm trying to do specifically in the patient-derived
organoid and see per stage if you can find some
kind of a... common factor which are really
upregulated or driving this stage from Barrett to
esophagus.
Mm-hmm. Great. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And our last speaker of the session today is Manrun Wu
from Baylor College of Medicine, who is going to talk about the role
of KMT2D,
in plasticity of lung cancer.
Hello, everybody, thanks for the invitation.
Today I will be giving a short talk on
one of the project titled, "KMT2D is a master epigenetic
regulator of lineage plasticity in lung squamous cell carcinoma."
Despite that
lung squamous cell carcinoma, also called LUSC,
being a common form of lung cancers, its
precise cellular origin remains elusive.
And although most LUSC are found in the central airway,
peripheral cases have also been reported to increase, suggesting
multiple cellular origin. A previous report has
suggested that the SOX2 amplification
could transform multiple cells, including lung
basal cell, club cell, as well as AT2 cell into
lung squamous cell carcinoma.
In addition, another study has also suggested that the LKB1
loss could transdifferentiate lung
adenocarcinoma into lung squamous cell
carcinoma via an intermediate mixed lung
adenosquamous state.
So in our lab, we are interested in whether there are additional genetic
mechanisms that could govern
such lineage transformation.
So the KMT2D is a major mammalian histone
H3K4 monomethyltransferase, and it is frequently
mutated in multiple types of cancer, including about
20% in lung squamous cell carcinoma.
And interestingly, a fairly recent study published in the Cancer Cell has
suggested that the KMT2D deletion could
transform the lung basal cell organoids into lung squamous
cell carcinoma in a p53-null context.
So given that lung
adenosquamous cell could occur
through the transition from the lung adenocarcinoma to squamous
cell carcinoma, we further hypothesized that the KMT2D
loss could further promote such lineage transition in a
well-characterized KRAS P53 lung
adenocarcinoma model.
In order to test this, a previous graduate student in our lab, he
crossed the KMT2D flux allele onto
this KP background and initiated tumors from
both the club cell as well as the AT2 cell.
Interestingly, we found that the KMT2D deletion could
significantly
reduce the overall survival in our KP model from both
the lung club and the AT2 initiated tumors.
Interestingly, we found that the lung adenosquamous
lesions occur exclusively in the
KMT2D null context, as we can see
here at the bottom right, that the keratin 5, which is a
marker of the lung squamous cell carcinoma, is possibly
present in this lesion only in the mutant case, but not in the
wild-type case.
So in order to further delineate the cellular
heterogeneity within our KP tumor models,
we
further crossed the tdTomato
reporter allele onto our model and employed
flow cytometry to isolate the tdTomato positive tumor cells
for 10X single nucleus multiomics sequencing, including
the RNA seq as well as the ATAC seq. And from
the unsupervised clustering on the left, we can see there are
13 transcriptionally distinguished states, including
multiple types of cells that are observed in the normal lungs,
including AT1, club, AT2, as well as
AT1/AT2 mix cell types.
We've also seen cell clusters that exhibited progenitor-like markers
such as CD44, positive progenitor-like cluster,
as well as integrin alpha 6 beta 4 stem-like cluster.
Comparing the abundance of different cellular clusters across
KMT2D deleted as well as wild
type from the club initiated tumors as well as the
AT2 derived tumors, we see that the
basal-like cluster is significantly enriched
in the KMT2D knockout
club initiated tumors.
Because of that, we further narrowed down our single nucleus
multiomics analysis on the club initiated tumors
and using RNA velocity to guide
on directionality within a
partition-based graph abstraction framework, we obtain an
unbiased connectivity map, which suggests that the integrin alpha 6 beta
4 stem-like cluster could be a intermediate stage
during this lineage transformation.And interestingly, we
see that this transdifferentiation
process could be further captured by the TCGA
lung adenocarcinoma, as well as the lung squamous cell carcinoma, as we
can see that the features of lung adenocarcinoma slightly goes down,
and then followed by the increase of the lung squamous cell
carcinoma features. And this process is accompanied by the
sequential elevation of the integral alpha 6, beta like stem
cell signature score, followed by the EMT signature
scores.
So in order to further examine the putative genes
during such transformation process, we further
calculated the gene scores using ArchR.
And from this developmental trajectory, we could see that
initially there are lung lineage genes such as
FOXA2, SCGB1A1, which is a club specific marker,
as well as the Nkx2.1. And followed
by the emergence of the
GI-related genes such as Milk 5AC as
well as HNF4 alpha. And till the end, we can see the
emergence of
lung squamous cell carcinoma-related transcriptional factors such as
TRP63 as well as SOX2.
And moreover, interestingly, we found that the open regions
in the KMT2D in no club initiated tumors but
closed in the wild type tumors. We observed those
regions are enriched with the chromatin modulators such
as the SMARCC1 and as well as the EP300.
We've also seen AP1 family such as the Fos and also
Jun. And interestingly, we found that there are
oxidative stress-related genes such as NFE2L2,
which is also called NRF2.
So we hypothesized that the
endodermal transcriptional factors such as the
FOXA1 and the FOXA2, could
determine the lineage through the KMT2D
regulated enhancer programs. So in order to do this, we
performed color run analysis on the wild type cell lines
that are derived from our KP models, and we
differentiate the FOXA1 and
FOXA2
based on the differential
binding sites between the wild type cell line as well as
our mutant cell line for the H3K4 monomethylation marks.
And we can see here that the FOXA1 and the FOXA2
binding sites are specifically enriched in
those regions where upon the KMT2D knockout
exhibit significant reduction of the H3K4
monomethylation, which suggests the potential interplay between the
FOXA1, FOXA2, as well as the KMT2D
protein.
Interestingly, because the FOXA1 is a very
important chromatin regulator, but its role in the
lung squamous cell carcinoma has never been explored.
So we wanted to see if there is a potential interplay between the
FOXA1 and
the SOX2.
So in order to do so, we performed the color run for the
FOXA1 and the SOX2 binding sites in our mutant cell line.
And surprisingly, we found a significant overlap of
those binding sites of those two transcriptional factors,
indicating a potential interplay between those two factors.
Moreover, a recent study has suggested that upon the
KMT2D deletion, there is an emergence of
other KMT2 families which harbor
MENNIN
emerge. So we wanted to know if there are further interplay between the
MENNIN, FOXA1, as well as the SOX2.
And as we can see here, comparing to wild type as well as
three mutant cell lines, we see a
redistribution as well as co-localization of some
binding sites of the FOXA1 and as well as SOX2, as well as
MENNIN suggesting an interplay between those three factors
upon the KMT2D deletion.
So in line with what we've observed in the color run analysis,
we've seen that the KMT2D protein
interacts physically strongly with FOXA1, but
slightly less with the FOXA2. And because
the
redistribution of the MENNIN, we further tested the
MI-503, which is a MENNIN inhibitor, and we found that the
mutant cell lines are more sensitive to this MENNIN
inhibitor compared to the wild type cell lines.
So in conclusion, the KMT2D loss could accelerate the
tumorigenesis and cause lineage switch towards squamous in the KP
lung tumor mouse model. And the single-nuclei multi-omics
profiling reveals that cellular dynamics of lineage transition
in the KMT2D null KP lung tumors.
Diminished endoderm differentiation program is associated with
the lineage transition towards the squamous in our KMT2D
null KP lung tumor.
And the KMT2D knockout contributes to the establishment
of squamous identity, presumably due to the
redistribution of MENNIN FOXA1 and SOX2.
So with all that, I would like to acknowledge all the members in
the Rai lab as well as Dr. Ling Gu for helpful discussion, as well
as Dr. Vena for her assistance with 10x
single-nucleus multiome.
And I would also like to thank three members from our
lab. And with that, I would like to take any questions.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for a great talk. I would like to open for questions.
I'll start. Very interesting work on KMT2D.
You probably are familiar with all the literature on catalytic activity
dependence or not. Do you know if the catalytic activity
in your setting is important for KMT2D?
Well, yeah.
And also any overlap with KMT2C as well?
Yes. I think for
the catalytic component, it's actually pretty important because
we've actually compared the survival
between
all the regions for the KMT2D gene, as well as
those that does not have any of the mutations.
So, we did not actually see a
significant difference at first for the overall survival.
But if we only look at the genes that are mutated,
for example, loss of function in the catalytic region, if we're only
focusing on those region, that's where we see a significant
decrease of the overall survival.
So we actually think that it is very important to only narrow down
to the specific regions.
And obviously the catalytic region is important because
that's
the site where the protein does the
enhancer regulator work. Right. Yeah.
And KMT2C overlap with KMT2D?
I think their jobs kind of overlap, but
I did not really look into study its role in this
context though. Yeah. Thank you.
Great. Yes, please.
Hi, this is Risha from Weill Cornell.
A very nice talk, and I've been following your lab's work for a long time now.
So, my question is, did you see any interaction of SOX2 and
KMT2D or-
SOX2 is a transcriptional factors in the lung
squamous cell carcinoma. So upon the knockout, we actually see
the increase of the expression of the
SOX2 in our mutant groups.
But you haven't seen any physical interaction like you saw for FOXA1 with
KMT2D.
Oh. We actually haven't tested that.
We are actually doing that, but we've only looked into
the physical interaction between the FOXA1 and the
FOXA2 with the KMT2D because those are very
important lung lineage determinant
endothermal transcriptional factors. Yeah.
Okay. And the second question is, I might have missed this, but
perturbing FOXA1, does that change the distribution or
activity of KMT2D?
Yes, it does. Actually, not only does it
change the localization, but also, I think, the overall
expression changes. It decreases,
but it doesn't mean that the activity really decreases, right,
like in some cases.
It doesn't really changes-
Yeah
... the specifications or-
It-
... specific locations where the KMT2D might have located, right?
It redistributes in our mutant context.
So it goes to different areas for binding, which kind of
supports this transdifferentiation
process.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi. Ace from UBC, Canada. I also have a question
regarding the redistribution after your knockout of
KMT2A. Have you really look into the specific
mechanism that causes the redistribution?
Because KMT2As are marker methyltransferase.
Is there any kind of potential reader of that marker that leads to the
redistribution?
You mean have I looked into the KMT2A-
Like, because KMT2-
Yeah. With the menin
... methyltransferase is for the marker, right?
So usually for the marker to function, you need a reader component to kind of
amplify how, like recruiting other components.
So I'm just wondering what is the specific mechanism between
redistribution and KMT2A itself.
Okay. So, the menin is actually
the other components that work with
KMT2A or B,
which overall becomes a chromatin remodeler.
And as the compact family,
they go to different areas for,
I think, not only enhancer regulator, but on also other
dimethylation.
Yeah. And trimethylation. I think for the menin, it's mostly trimethylation, but in
our case, we're focusing mainly on the
monomethylation marks. But what we found was that upon that
deletion of the KMT2D gene, which
is a enhancer regulator that marks the
H3K4 monomethylation, we observe a
redistribution of H3K4 trimethylation
mark associated protein, which is menin.
So
yeah. Does that answer the question?
Have you also look into the reader of those markers redistribution as
well?
No,
we have not.
But we could look into that. Yeah.
Sure.
Thank you.
Really nice work. I was interested if you've looked at
differential H3K27 acetylation since you saw P300 as
one of your enriched factors, and it's a known interactor of KMT2D.
Hmm. Yes. So, we compared the...
Well, overall,
I think for the H3K27
acetylation,
it decreased a little bit compared
to-- Because that's really in align with what
we've seen in the H3K4 monomethylation mark, because we
expected to see a global slight reduction.
But actually, for the single
nucleus-RNA ATAC-seq,
we've observed the somewhat opposite,
but we think that it might be because
of the
specific clusters that we've observed.
For example, the integrin stem-like cluster, as well as the
progenitor markers. Those clusters may
have more
H3K27 acetylation
that's
really recruiting those chromatin marks that
helps it to open the chromatin. But
for the cell line, we did not really compare
the H3K27 acetylation.
Yeah.
Thanks.
No problem. Thanks.
Go ahead.
Yeah. Cathy O'Connor from the Markey Cancer Center.
I really enjoyed your talk. I was very curious about your
interpretation of the ALK6 beta 4 stem-like
profile as being kind of opposite of the EMT
profile. I was-
I wouldn't say it's opposite. I would say it's actually more like a
precursor of the EMT. I think it's actually
the emergence of the integrin alpha 6, and then
followed by the EMT, because there are other cell
clusters that exhibit more EMT features
compared to the integrin alpha 6 beta stem-like
cluster. And we actually found that the
stem-like cluster actually precedes
that EMT small cluster. And we find that this is very
interesting because
those could be precursor cells that could later
exhibit more EMT features before
the non-squamous features occur.
Okay. I just find it really interesting because my lab studies how
integrin alpha 6 beta 4 regulates epigenome as well as the
transcriptional profiles in triple-negative breast cancer.
Oh, okay.
So we actually find that a lot of the
EMT drivers, the things that really drive invasion and
metastasis in triple negative, are actually driven by alpha 6 beta 4.
So it has to be disassembled in order for EMT to
actually occur. So I was just-
Mm.
-wondering your interpretation of that. Maybe we can talk afterwards.
Yeah, sure.
Thank you.
Great. So let us all thank the speaker.
So this concludes our session, Advances in Cancer Epigenetics.
I want to thank all of you for coming to the great session, my co-chair,
Daria, and all the speakers.
I want to highlight a little bit some of the major themes.
As you heard, epigenetic regulators, they are really affecting
tumorigenesis and also lineage plasticity.
We heard a lot of talks, especially in prostate cancer and the transfer
from androgen-dependent prostate cancer to neuroendocrine
prostate cancer that doesn't depend on androgens.
And we observed the role of the chromatin regulator
CHD7 on that. We also observed the role of the
demethylase KDM5, especially in the setting of
P10OL, and also further talks on lineage plasticity,
especially on KMT2D, and that change in
lung squamous cell carcinoma. So epigenetic regulators are not
only affecting tumorigenesis, such as also in the role
of KDM2A in esophagus progression, but also
they are leading to lineage transition and also guiding
this change in differentiation. And also we heard important
insights on DNA methylation and EZH2 in
prostate cancer, also in colorectal cancer.
And lastly, this highlights the need to really study these basic
mechanisms so we can inform clinical care,
especially we have new therapies that potentially might
merge into preclinical work and to the clinical work, such
as targeting the ubiquitin reader function of
DNMT1. So as a field, we have a lot of work to do.
We can see that the role of each of these factors is very lineage
dependent, cell dependent, and also hopefully by
understanding basic mechanisms, we can try to target these
factors and also influence therapy and
improve the patients' lives. So thank you all so much.
Thank you.
And thanks a lot, audience, for all your questions.
I think we had very lively discussions, so really appreciate it.
Thank you so much, and we'll see you next time.
Yep.
See you.
Goodbye.